[Musique]
bonjour je vous parlais surtout de
coopération je vais vous parler des
compétences dont nous avons besoin pour
mieux vaut payer à la famille au travail
et dans la vie sociale en général quand
je démarre une conférence en fait je
suis triste et je suis stressé parce que
je suis seul et que vous êtes membre
vous êtes plusieurs mais du coup je suis
stressé parce que je me dis qu'il ya
plus d'intelligence de compétences et
d'expériences plus d'histoire ici que là
et en plus si je me rends compte que je
dois vous apporter quelque chose que
vous ne connaissez pas encore alors que
j'ai pas de temps vous poser à chacun la
question de ce que vous venez apprendre
connaître que je vous connais pas alors
le stress est immense et le risque c'est
que je parte m'asseoir heureusement j'ai
une autre petite voix qui me dit quelque
chose de plus cool qui veut dit que si
je suis là c'est parce que j'ai fait est
que si vous êtes là c'est juste que pour
le moment vous avez suffisamment d'à
priori favorable pour rester là alors là
c'est déjà plus coup je me semble quel
lien avec la coopération mais bien avec
la coopération c'est que je suis
passionné depuis très longtemps sur le
fait que je crois que un plus un ses
supérieurs à nous alors je suis
ingénieur mais comme vous pouvez le voir
je pas très bons en calcul
les professeurs de battre mon comptable
d'un précis pas trop ce genre du pq mais
par contre je suis passionné par les
systèmes et dans un système on sait que
le tout est supérieure à la somme des
parties
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que lui
nous que nous formons et c'est à la fois
évidemment la la la somme des
personnalités que nous sommes chacun
avec ses compétences
avec son expérience
avec sa personnalité avec son histoire
avec sa manière de voir les choses et en
même temps le nous que nous formons ils
vivent pas seulement
et pour répondre de chacun il va
dépendre aussi des liens que nous allons
avoir les uns avec les autres
vous l'aurez pas après la pause j'espère
qu'il y avait bien un truc entre nous ce
que nous allons faire ensemble nous
allons produire va dépendre à la fois
évidemment les compétences de chacun
mais va dépendre aussi et bien que nous
allons créer les uns avec les autres
est ce que ça veut dire que le 1 + 1 est
toujours supérieure à 2
c'est pas mon expérience jardiner en
fait non j'aime pas vraiment jardiner
j'aime planté et mon mari c'est tout le
reste il taille courbe dans la foule et
au début quand on a commencé à jardiner
ça se passait à peu près comme ça je
plantais je plantais trade légumes dans
la pelouse
j'allais à la jardinerie j'achetais des
petites pousses de 5 cm de hauteur que
j'ai planté avec application au milieu
de la pelouse en disant qu'en salles et
fleury salles est jolie ces petites
fleurs sceptiques rochus des petites
gens qui voient là et d'autres fleurs je
me disais ça va être super etc et la
semaine d'après on marie passer la
tondeuse et il coupait tout alors
j'étais très bonne en plantations pas
aux plantages plantations mon mari était
très compétent pour passer là pour deux
mais collectivement c'était pas top
c'était pas top à la fois pour ce que
nous produisions ensemble vous ne sont
pas très performant collectivement
c'était pas top non plus j'ai envie de
dire pour le relationnel
pour la joie pour la satisfaction
j'avais quand même quelques reproches et
ce qui m'a intéressé c'est de voir là
qu'est ce qui fait que parfois quand
vous mettez ensemble ce que nous
produisons ressent vraiment quelque
chose qui est supérieur à ce que nous
aurions fait chacun et qui parfois c'est
assez désespérant et glacières
insatisfaisant quand j'ai pas mal
d'années déjà la photo est pas très
bonne santé alors numérique
j'ai travaillé chez matra transport
international qui est une entreprise qui
fabrique des métros et d'automatismes de
métro automatique et on était passionné
par des suidés conception de nouveaux
systèmes de transport pour permettre aux
gens tir et placé avec plus de fluidité
et plus de sécurité plus de simplicité
plus de confort et ses photos je les ai
gardé parce que pour moi elle symbolise
vraiment ce que j'aime vivre dans les
équipes quelque chose de la magie
disparaît dans un orchestre ce que j'ai
appris en fait dans cette expérience
c'est plusieurs choses mais entre autres
que dans la complexité dans lequel nous
sommes hélas on ne souvient pas des
systèmes complexes comme un système
compliqué la première chose c'est que
chaque personne ne peut dire je sais on
fait chacun un point de vue voilà partis
que la système à une partie des
informations mais aucun d'entre nous n'a
l'ensemble des informations qui nous
permette de résoudre les systèmes que
nous avons pas résolu les problèmes nous
avons raison et du coup on a besoin de
compter les uns sur les autres on a
besoin de s'écouter
la deuxième chose que j'ai expérimenté
c'est que comme ça quand on a des
difficultés sur les projets finalement
c'est vraiment les compétences
techniques ce qui donne souvent c'est
les relations entre une gros problème
c'est que j'avais pas appris à être en
relation
enfin j'avais appris d'une manière assez
sommet c'est que j'avais appris à avoir
raison et à essayer de convaincre
l'autre que s'il n'était pas d'accord
avec moi fallait qu'ils changent d'avis
c'était super simple en fait ça marche
pas ça marche pas au travail est alors à
la maison ça marche un moment je me suis
rendu compte que finalement j'avais pas
appris à rentrer en relation
ces stars qui crée la magie ou pas de la
réussite d'un projet quand je suis
arrivé chez matra transport
international l'entreprise venait de
vivre un traumatisme avec un projet qui
s'appelait le projet analystes l'arabie
c'était un projet extraordinaire un
projet parfait avec des petites voitures
on le voit là tout petit qui pouvait
s'attacher en 100 kg est haché ensemble
se détacher s'attacher et l'idée c'était
que par un passager allait prendre une
voiture à sa station de départ allait
pouvoir aller jusqu'à cette incitation
d'arrivée sans avoir à s'arrêter entre
les stations puisqu'il allait choisir la
voiture qui faisait son trajet avec
d'autres voyageurs
il avait la médiation et puis en
fonction des besoins des voyageurs en
fait une voiture allait s'assembler de
différentes manières ce projet a
fonctionné pendant 15 ans il a occupé
des dizaines probablement des centaines
d'ingénieurs personne et tout d'un coup
il s'arrêter il a coûté je crois plus
près ce sont 10 millions d'euros puis
soudainement s'est arrêté vers les
années 90 quelque chose comme ça moi je
n'arrivais pas prêt
c'était franchement un sujet tabou dans
l'entreprise mais moi j'ai voulu savoir
qu'est ce qui s'était passé parce que
j'avais pas envie de revivre la même
chose en fait je me dis ça doit être
terrible
le passé 15 ans à aller bosser tous les
matins allez perdre des heures et des
heures de travail
beaucoup de gens vous disent finalement
tout ce que tu as fait pendant quinze
ans ça sert à rien tu aurais pu faire du
premier prendre des vacances
l'équipe était enfant voilà je suis dit
ça j'ai pas mal pour un milieu alors je
suis allé chercher un petit peu et comme
je trouvais pas tellement de réponse
dans l'entreprise les bulles en
particulier la livre le livre de bruno
latour que vous voyez ici qu'est un
livre assez technique mais dans ce livre
j'avais surligner à l'époque en passage
beaucoup inspiré et qui au fond explique
la démarche que j'ai eu après
communication non violente alors je vais
vous lire parce que ce passage vraiment
m'a parlé et il me paraît vraiment
important pour vous imaginez en fait
quand j'allais chez matra transport
international tous les matins j'allais
au parking sous sol modéré ma voiture et
en passant pour ranger ma voiture dans
le parking vont passer devant une
voiture arabi qui était un peu le
symbole du projet qui avait motivé fait
rêver des tas de gens et qui finalement
était un échec
alors imaginez si arabiste c'est d'être
au départ les voilà ce qu'il vous tirait
donc je parle à la place du métro
évidemment vous allez comprendre
j'espère surtout ne pas discuter non pas
douter ne pas négocier ne pas
s'affronter mais ce n'est pas ainsi
qu'on aime et être de la sorte une
effrayante conspiration du silence
voilà ce qui m'a imposé le silence
j'existerai le contraire si vous aviez
parlé
vous aimez le silence c'est à moi de le
porter par vous les humains
vous devez parler vous devez discuter
vous devez vous cacher c'est votre route
s'il va toucher dans cette expérience
c'est profond personnes c'était la faute
de personne si ce projet s'est arrêté
personne était coupable
par contre ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
avaient personnes qui pendant le projet
avait pas rien et qu'on n'avait pas les
personnes qui avait dit ce projet allait
trop vite et les personnes qui avait dit
ce projet il répond pas vraiment aux
besoins des villes aujourd'hui d'autres
qui avait dit ce projet il n'est pas
vraiment fait pour la circulation dans
les villes
il serait plus utile dans des navettes
sur
circuit mais ces gens là pour les a pas
écoutés parce que le projet est
tellement génial et on a continué les
personnes qui est dit dans ce projet
continue à vouloir réaliser le projet
extraordinaire jusqu'à se rendre compte
à la fin au moment où signé sur les
thèmes de wade sait c'est pratiquement
la fois du projet le finalement ce
projet ils étaient inexploitables et
répondait pas aux besoins des clients
sam un téléfilm et du coup je me suis
dit mais moi je veux pas vivre ça je
veux pas vivre ça dans mon travail je
crois que vous porte pire je veux pas
vivre ça dans ma famille je ne voudrais
pas éduquer mes enfants et me rendent
compte qu avant
finalement ce que j'ai fait c'est parce
qu'il fallait en fait d'accord mais du
coup je me suis dit finalement la chose
la plus importante bien sûr nous avons
chacun nos compétences techniques dont
compétence métier mais en même temps ce
qui va faire la réussite de nos projets
c'est la qualité des liens nous allons
avoir les uns avec les autres et en
particulier capacité à écouter celui un
avis différent du nôtre c'est facile de
rester à toulouse avec des personnes qui
pensent comme lui et de se conforter
dans nos idées ça me fait du bien mais
en même temps je crois et je croyais
dans la société actuelle dans les enjeux
qui sont les nôtres aujourd'hui c'est
indispensable pour la prem à dialoguer
avec des personnes qui ont des points de
vue différents des nôtres
depuis j'ai rencontré un processus
s'appelle la communication non violente
qui m'a vraiment permis de comprendre
quelles sont les compétences qui me
permettent de discuter avec quelqu'un
quand je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui
voilà bah
comme il est comme moi il a dépensé il
observe des choses il ressent des choses
là des besoins fondamentaux fait des
choix
alors voilà ce qui se passe avec bob on
travaille ensemble sur un projet et on a
une décision à prendre qui va avoir un
impact important pour nous dans les deux
ans à vous et je trouve que c'est génial
la coopération les pubs on a fait le
travail fait plusieurs mois qu'on a faim
ne peut travail réfléchir à cette
décision qu'on devait prendre
on a écouté les avis tout vente j'ai pu
donner des idées qui était vraiment
super génial et il les a écoutés c'est
toi je suis dit ça c'est la coopération
je veux c'est génial on s'écoute on fait
des propositions entièrement 10 habitent
chacun
j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire sauf que
ce matin bob vient me voir et il dit que
finalement il a pris une autre décision
qui est complètement opposé à toutes les
idées qu'on a vu pendant le groupe de
travail là je me dis que franchement
j'espère que ça vous arrive jamais ce
truc là parce que c'est juste
insupportable et là comment je fais
comment je fais pour continuer à couper
l'ex bob qui va prendre une idée débile
alors je précise le combat parce que ça
va marcher
la communication non violente en fait
elles me permettent de choses la
première c'est de rappeler mon intention
pourquoi je vais mettre de l'énergie
pour être en relation avec sa fabrique
ça va me demander du temps ça va me
demander de l'énergie ça va me demander
de l'énergie émotionnel aussi dans le
texte que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
on va peut-être se fâcher et en même
temps je vais le faire parce que je me
rends compte qu'il ya plusieurs choses
qui me pousse à le faire en fait la
première c'est que on a un projet
commande et que je me dis que si on veut
réussir ses projets communs la fête
intérêt à être en relation et j'ai envie
de dire le un puissant est supérieur à
bloc la table la deuxième chose et je
sais que nous sommes tous
interdépendants
c'est à dire je sais que ce que je fais
un impact sur bob en a pas sur vous ce
combat me faire un avis sur moi et
peut-être même sur vous parce que nous
faisons va voir l'impact sur vous ce que
vous faites un impact sur moi et du coup
je me dis que peut-être ça vaut le coup
quand même essayer de construire quelque
chose d'une relation constructive
même si c'est un peu compliqué et puis
la troisième chose j'en veux dire c'est
que je rencontre chaque fois que
j'expérimente sa j'apprends des choses
je brandis j'évolue et du coup j'ai un
peu de curiosité comment alors comment
ça va se passer ça ça c'est la première
chose donc je vais entrer en relation
avec moi la deuxième chose c'est que la
clé la coopération ça va pas être
échangé au niveau de nos pensées le
jugement pour essayer de savoir qui a
tort qui a raison de façon je sais c'est
moins qu'à raison donc la question se
pose pas mais la clé de la coopération
c'est ça vraiment mais j'ai découvert
une communication non violente
s'il écoute que nos besoins fondamentaux
et besoins fondamentaux c'est comme la
source
ce qui nous motive tout nos jugements le
sentiment que paroles nos actions le
choix sont prêts à leur source dans
quelque chose qui nous motive à agir que
la manière dont on agit davantage nous
relier avec les besoins fondamentaux
c'est qu'on se relit vraiment
la motivation profonde et personnes
alors ça commencerait comment ça
commencerait par l'auteur baptisé quels
sont les besoins
c'est ce que je me dis je me dis que
vraiment c'est nul cette situation c'est
nul parce que je viens de perdre trois
mois et moi ont besoin prioritaire c'est
de faire un bon usage
mon temps et mon énergie ça c'est
vraiment important comment jeter un test
avant qu'après je vais donner l'empathie
album jeunesse y voir qu est ce qui est
précieux schiphol on va discuter vois
pas ce que tu prends une décision parce
que c'était la plus légère
toi n'en faites pas ça c'est que en
sortant de discussion j'ai vu les
décisions qu'il avait prises qu'on avait
décidé moi je n'arrivais pas à me les
approprier et moi j'ai besoin de me
sentir en intégralité avec la décision
je prends hockey est-ce que tant besoin
c'est d'être en intégrité
damman ça prend plus de temps ok existe
un bon jeu peut relier aux besoins voilà
on a besoin de faire un peu nous
agissons entendons bien besoin de vérité
là quelque chose à mon père qui souffre
parce que je vois qu'on n'est pas l'un
contre l'autre
aussi je connais besoin intégrité et du
coup on va pouvoir construire quelque
chose qui va prendre soin des besoins de
chacun par exemple je pourrais demander
à bob route parce que la prochaine fois
faire le manque de travail
est-ce que tu serais d'accord vous
donnez un peu les limites donc à toi tu
te sens l'intégrité comme ça moi je sais
où je mets mon énergie je vous garantis
que si vous écoutez les besoins
fondamentaux qui vous a line hi les
besoins fondamentaux qui anime l'autre
au maximum trois quarts d'heure vous
trouverez absolument et je voudrais
finir par un proverbe inscrits 1 j'aime
beaucoup il dit pour les branches se
querellent et raciste s'embrassent
bâtie
[Applaudissements]